6 13 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well we may not like
those orange cones the construction
projects that slow us down every day but
we should not ignore or disrespect the
men and women who put on the hard hats
and the brightly colored vest to get the
work done it's part of national work
Zone awareness week I want you to check
out the folks on the Utah Department of
Transportation you found a cool way to
drive home the point that every person
on every work crew has a family
he comes to all my baseball games
he makes me laugh with his funny jokes
the leader of my Scout group
she gives me hugs and kisses and keeps
me safe
because the things he does helps all of
us
blr our parents are at work
yeah they're people too and I'm pretty
sure everybody at the Nevada Department
of Transportation would say here here
and we may be able to show you some of
the hard-working best-wearing folks from
the Silver State coming soon to a screen
or website near you buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com again it's no fun
driving through the construction zones
and some people actually do treat them
poorly if you would like to join in the
conversation the email address
traffic88newsnow.com you have to be so
careful we had a couple of flaggers
killed really in the last years yes
there's some alarming statistics it's so
safe out there be courteous to everyone
why not right they're just doing their
job one day there will be no more
construction everything will be finished
right Nate or whatever all the roads
will be perfect yeah in fact it's going
to be finished on the 12th excellent
there will be unicorns running down the
highway the 12th of Never